no se fue la luz se apaga las f no se
preocupen
empiezo esta plática balón antes de todo
muchísimas gracias por la invitación de
fort hood y muchísimas gracias a esta
universidad por darme este tiempo
incluso esta plática en obscuridad
porque hablaremos de innovación entonces
hay que hacer algo innovador hay que
innovar también un poco esta plática
esta conferencia
porque la oscuridad
porque hace unas décadas hace 100 años
hace mil años el ser humano vivía en la
obscuridad no existe la luz tal vez
ahorita yo podrías utilizar una vela
pero ya estamos en una era digital
estamos en una sociedad moderna donde
prácticamente utilizamos esto
y no ves tengo mi linterna no te
preocupes para que utilizo la vela no
estás loco estamos en 2019
bueno
podemos empezar
entonces esto qué significa significa
que
la tecnología la innovación ya es parte
de nosotros no no creo que existe lo yo
ustedes den se cuenta en todo su día
cuántas veces utilizan su teléfono
apagar las linternas baterías de escape
cuántas veces utilizamos nosotros
teléfono o ipad todo demás gps
aplicaciones móviles social mi lector o
demás bueno pero entonces aquí la
cuestión es de forma un poco teatral
to innovate or not to innovate that is
the question okay innovarse innovarse es
el dilema
hagamos una dinámica
ya que es parte de esta forma innovador
de presentar si se pueden poner por
favor en mi perfil ahí encontrarán
algunas preguntas donde yo les voy a
estar haciendo y donde ustedes no van a
dar unas respuestas para que haya más
interacción en lo que estamos haciendo
que entonces a mí me gusta mucho el
engagement me gustaría estar un
escenario con ustedes darme vueltas
preguntarles de los ojos no y mucho más
ser la tecnología pero pues hay que
platicar de normas son entonces
utilizamos bien lo que la tecnología nos
da todos los días
las visiones de innovación son varias
obviamente tenemos a gurús muy
importantes a nivel mundial donde
prácticamente dan su punto de vista
acerca de innovación uno es ser jobs
ojalá que todos aquí lo que estamos
sentados somos líderes no y no volverse
ok innovation y este only way to win
feiler is not an option here elon musk
que dice algo muy importante que es
parte un factor determinante de
innovación si tú no te arriesgas
automáticamente no vas a innovar
cuando van a estar en el mundo de los
negocios
obviamente hay que ser muchos intentos
para sacar algo digamos eficiente
productivo pero qué pasa a un sistema
tradicional a una empresa donde se rige
digamos de valores pues convencionales
tradicionales históricos donde les da
miedo un cambio donde no se arriesgan
ahí es parte de la gente
innovar traer nuevas ideas
entonces pueden poner ponerse mi perfil
por favor de una vez
en instagram quien lo tiene obviamente
y bueno la primera pregunta que verán es
esta
después de ario brevemente que se están
listos cuál es la principal
característica de un innovador y aquí
está hay días o solución vamos a ver un
ratito que contesta en esta pregunta qué
piensan ustedes bueno no hay ninguna
respuesta correcta
o sea me refiero que eso es subjetivo
entonces obviamente la innovación lleva
una idea obviamente cada innovación
lleva una solución sin duda y sin
embargo there's no hay día
ok antes de la innovación siempre a una
idea una idea destructiva una idea que
va afuera de lo común que yo espero
haberles compartido de una manera muy
sencilla tal vez empezando esta
conferencia algo diferente algo original
empezar sin luz
y empezar a interactuar con social media
la gente estaba bueno pues yo también
hubiera pensado pero pues hay que
practicarlo no hay que arriesgarse en
esto
entonces solamente tenemos dos mundos el
mundo dark del pasado con poca luz con
pocas inversiones con pocos
descubrimientos el mundo de hoy que es
un mundo que lleno de luz hasta diría
que hace con un caos de información con
un saturn nos saturan con muchísima
información o con casi un caos
y entonces en la sociedad moderna lo que
está pasando pues tenemos ejemplos
prácticos de la televisión a los martín
y de los teléfonos al internet de la
televisión normal ahorita los netflix en
el centro de más del trabajo digamos
manual al trabajo robótico hay muchas
muchas experiencias en este sentido no
entonces en este caso lo que estamos
viendo es algo que para nosotros normal
pero a ver nuestros papás de abuelos
seguramente han vivido en otro tipo de
sociedad entonces creo que ahorita
estamos practicando esto no me imagino
cómo va a ser la sociedad en 2050 yo
creo que la conferencia ni siquiera va a
ser así la conferencia de hacer tal vez
no estar disponibles pongamos en un
holograma yo de manera remota voy a
estar dando mi plática desde otro lado
del mundo
pero dónde están los centros de
innovación a nivel mundial
porque nosotros siempre platicamos a ese
país es más innovador ya está creciendo
silicon valley new york city europa
mexico que ahorita vamos a tocar como
estamos en innovación bueno pues aquí es
un mapa es un mapa que obviamente con
más tiempo se puede platicar mucho más a
detalle pero para dar un poquito una
duración mapa en este caso a nivel
mundial aquí son señores aquí son las
mentes brillantes que están cambiando el
mundo
entonces tenemos desde silicon valley
super conocido no
compuesto por las más importantes
empresas a nivel tech a nivel
tecnológico con uber con todos los demás
con google
tenemos new york city capital importante
de la innovación en este caso es líder
en la finca tenemos a londres que es una
capital de innovación en este caso de
venture capital acerca de technology
tenemos hasta com en suecia que es como
considerado el unicornio europeo
entonces son startups en este caso
tecnológicas que tienen budget en este
caso utilidad pues solamente enormes no
y tenemos no solamente el caso de
norteamericana el caso europeo también
tenemos los nuevos continentes que
obviamente se están innovando y que por
eso están creciendo y de hecho ahorita
vamos a ver cómo que están proponiendo
pues nuevas tecnologías que nosotros
mismos estamos adoptando tenemos cerca
de shenzhen en china con huawei y todas
las demás marcas que conocemos tenemos
el caso de australia como autor y bueno
y todo lo demás que ahorita vamos a
platicar con más detalle entonces
tenemos mayor tenemos san francisco
tenemos
según ustedes méxico es un país
innovador según ustedes méxico está
aprovechando la tecnología de la
innovación como otros países lo están
haciendo están aportando beneficios
importantes para la sociedad
la respuesta es
en teoría es uno que luego pasa por un
si es un nada porque bueno pues según
datos de la ocde
el budget está dirigido en este caso
research and development que es digamos
la área principal de la sociedad de un
país y de una empresa para que pueda
innovar algo que ya existe buena méxico
se dirige solamente el 0.5 del pib
claramente superior con respecto a otros
países latinoamericanos pero perdón
méxico es méxico entonces tenemos que
compararnos con lo mejor vamos vamos más
allá vamos vamos beyond the walls ok
entonces otros países obviamente como
los que le mencioné desde un corea del
sur pasando por suecia pasando por
israel bueno ellos de ellos dirigen
hasta 23 por ciento de su pib en este
caso en el resort develop entonces hay
mucho que hacer
ojalá activamente en este caso sector
público fomenten pulse ese sector tan
estratégico para todos nosotros no en
este caso
claramente si nos preguntamos existe un
silicon valley mexicano
pues la respuesta sería así
guadalajara no sé si lo sabían pero pues
es considerada como la silicon valley
del país entonces tenemos muchos
ejemplos importantes en este caso en
jalisco hay una sinergia muy bien hecho
en este caso entre un gobierno y el
sector entre el sector público en estado
privada entre el sector educativo en la
estado privada entonces esto obviamente
está ayudando muchísimo a que muchas
empresas multinacionales en este caso
tecnológicas innovadoras pues están
invirtiendo literal y tratando de
innovar hasta su mismo negocio en
tenemos casos como ahora que tenemos
casos como y bien tenemos muchos casos
en este caso de multinacionales a nivel
internacional que ya están tomando en
cuenta lo que es guadalajara que estamos
al principio no podemos comparar una
silicon valley en este caso en méxico
con la silicon valley que acabo de
mencionarles no pero todo hay que
empezar todo hay que arrancar entonces
en este caso estamos viendo porque tal
vez todavía
esta silicon valley en méxico nuestra
consolidada o no está al nivel de las
demás
porque perdón todos podemos todos
podemos todo está aquí innovación está
en su brain y no son está en tus ideas
no esto no está en algo de la fuerza
ayudas recomendaciones dinero fascinó
pero al final todo está nuestra mente si
nosotros mismos no pensamos en algo
nuevo no pensamos en algo out of the box
todo es inútil
entonces aquí son tres factores en este
caso principales en donde en este caso
tal vez un país está fallando y no puede
estar considerado como silicon valley a
nivel internacional
entonces como les dije algunos ejemplos
a nivel mundial donde se están haciendo
sinergias muy importantes entre sectores
públicos y privados en el sector
educativo iniciativa privada entre
financiamientos y recursos financieros
por parte de grandes empresas con
startups y empresas de emprendedores en
este caso en el tecnológico bueno pues
hay que buscar esto cuando falla esto
pues obviamente es muy difícil crear una
innovación y si no es difícil pues
solamente se va a tardar mucho más
tiempo tal vez hasta décadas y al final
del proceso tal vez ni siquiera va a
ocurrir que haga que haya digamos una
entonces hay que apostar muchísimo en el
talento local hay ejemplos en méxico
obviamente donde donde tenemos que
ustedes conocen como aeroespacial es
automotriz estamos aquí en la cuna del
sector automotriz que ustedes saben
perfectamente y saben perfectamente
también que muchas universidades fueron
enfocadas en esto de promover lo que son
carreras y licenciaturas
obviamente dirigidas a lo que el sector
de mercado está presente entonces en
este caso sector automotriz los
ingenieros industriales todo esto la
unam obviamente nos dice que hay muchos
investigadores
y creo que ha leído muchas noticias
hasta en los medios de comunicación es
donde donde yo colaboro ponemos de
mexicanos que ganan y que en este caso
prevalecen sobré sobre otros sujetos en
varias competencias internacionales en
investigación es todo de más pero que lo
que hace falta son ingenieros lo que
hace falta son personas que obviamente
técnicas profesionales que puedan estar
ahí ayudando en todo esto y además de
esto pues obviamente hay que
actualizarse en las listas mundiales hay
que saber entender el chip obviamente en
innovación y hay que saber entonces
también hacer todas estas alianzas
porque sin un sistema detrás no se puede
tampoco crear un hub de innovación a
siderar de un día al otro no
es un dato para que vean un poquito cuál
es la relación entre innovación y
crecimiento ya que vimos un poco los
países a nivel mundial y ahorita a nivel
ya más local antes las empresas se
tardaban 102 años para posicionarse en
el mercado 102 años ahora se tardan
solamente 14 años
increíble y esto lo demuestra
con estos gráficos que demuestran la
evolución de las marcas más valiosas del
planeta donde prácticamente se muestran
las marcas de hace 20 años que eran las
líderes literal del mercado mundial y
cómo han evolucionado con el pasar de
los años como and evolution también
ellas pero mismas con este cambio
tecnológico cómo se ha relacionado con
la transformación digital cómo se ha
relacionado con el nuevo público meta
con las nuevas generaciones con los
milenios y generaciones
de todo lo demás bueno pues vemos hace
20 años la potencia era pues cocacola
típica marca en este caso que representa
pues el el consumismo masivo del siglo
pasado no pero como vemos después
obviamente hubieron cambios entonces fue
la entrada de nuevos players en este
mercado mundial entonces tenemos por
ejemplo a paul igual que muy pocos años
como pueden ver en diez años llegaron a
los primeros lugares a nivel mundial
eso es algo increíble
y en 2018
julia desplazó a coca-cola y bueno pues
después de públicamente ya llegaron a
estar presentes solamente pues como le
dije google y también otra importante
negocio tecnológico instructivo pues
facebook facebook en los últimos años en
su mente ha crecido muchísimo gracias a
sus transformaciones digitales y
tecnológicas bueno entonces en pocas
palabras si queremos un poquito
idealizarlo pues el iphone se comió al
vic beck no en pocas palabras
casi terminó pero quiero terminar con
una reflexión
porque yo mismo no solo no sólo niego
voy a improvisar un poquito o estar un
poco fuerte la presentación voy a
innovar porque me sale una idea y quiero
ponerla en acto
yo vivía en la capital mexicana bueno
pues me levanto checo el taxi de las
aplicaciones ahorita y como 34
competidores en este caso de movilidad
llego allá esto mi oficina trabajo si me
da tiempo como cuando como pido un
servicio de delivery también aplicación
digital luego pide otras cosas y
converse cuando no puedo estar en las
tiendas comprando y después para
regresar a mi casa hay mucho tráfico ya
no utilizo los taxis están los
monopatines está la bicicleta compartida
o sea me refiero que soy muy jack me
encanta ser muy futurista me encanta
también utilizar mucha tecnología en el
día a día pero sin embargo
creo que todos tenemos una esencia y es
importante destacar algo que también hay
que saber cómo utilizarla
acuérdense que la tecnología por ejemplo
nos acerca muchísimo en este caso en la
razón tecnológica
hablamos con personas de otro lado del
mundo nos conocen interactuamos con
personas de otro continente
de manera simultánea instantánea pero
qué pasa luego está al lado nuestro
conocido nuestro amigo ahorita como
ustedes tal vez se van a perder después
su celular y una persona al lado está
lista para conversar como para compartir
su vida con una con ustedes y se pierden
entonces yo puse no todo es oro lo que
reluce o sea hay que estar de todas
maneras conscientes de estos cambios la
innovación es padrísima pero ojo tampoco
hay que tener solamente la innovación y
síntomas no se encuentra en este caso
los valores que también origen pues las
personas una sociedad de problemas
entonces
aprovechemos las tecnologías pero que no
que nosotros nos estén utilizando y le
puse un ejemplo tal vez que lo sabían o
no pero facebook está considerada como
empresa es destructiva innovadores de
los demás por lo que su facebook es
crear más consumo masivo con la
tecnología los early adopters sale un
iphone lo que sea bueno qué pasa hay
filas perdón kilométrica de personas
ustedes crean que esas personas que
hacen estas filas kilométricas lo que
necesitan lo que urgen su vida es un
iphone no contesta me lo creo
con todo respeto con la marca y steve
jobs y todo lo que quieras pero entonces
de qué estamos hablando que también es
un juego que se está haciendo y que
tenemos que estar con mucho cuidado no
en este caso
entonces la dinámica de las series
sociales si quieren la encuentran en mi
instagram
y me gusta que compartieran ahí entonces
sus ideas también sus respuestas para
que también entendamos un poquito ese
dónde vamos y espero que han disfrutado
esta plática y les dejo en buenas manos
con los otros pitchers muchas gracias